your art is all over your house and it's
fantastic your very sitar think you so
much he's just blanketed his house with
his art and you do you do some really
compelling stuff oh thanks you're quite
prolific I notice a lot of it some of
its provocative thinking it does me
actually but that the art does me it's
like it's not something I can help it's
a symptom of something yeah yeah yeah
there's a lot of angst and you know
worry and anger going on and it just
seems to have manifested in in me
hunched over an art table bug dare me
what started as a compliment turned into
the saddest thing I've heard and well
let's uncork it well for example I think
we have just is just like I think two
examples there yeah that's fencing yeah
right this is our leader being taken for
a ride who's in control yeah this next
one I didn't understand there's there's
I mean our our president yes that's our
praising icecream yeah the sensual
experience but you know you uh you
sketch off and you sketch very well and
you had said that you might yeah sketch
while you're out here and I do it
I wanted to I want to do a little sketch
of you Conan you don't touch with me
this is my testing I think it's only
fair if you actually attempt to do a
sketch of me as well and then you'll see
this energy that I've been bitten by
it's amazing so cuz I anomaly I am NOT a
talented artist I am NOT you know but
justjust just draw what you see just go
out what you see you look at me
okay and you feel what's inside okay and
then you just draw what you seen you
just go with it all right you're gonna
do do me and I will do you as they say
let's let's talk while we do this and
continue the interview or if we must you
were a very funny kid
you were always a funny kid and I heard
that you used to when you were growing
up when a visitor came to the house you
would greet them in a very interesting
way is that yes I I would throw myself
down a giant flight of stairs in front
of the guests is that really true that's
true
actually I would heave myself down this
giant stairway and and then I would get
up when they were shocked out of their
minds that I would get up and I would
say let's see that again in slow motion
go back up to the top of the stairs and
and I would attempt to do it again in
slow motion I would hit every step on
the way down like that and I would end
up yes
at the bottom of the stairs at their
feet and they and then my father would
come in with his patented line which he
loved to do which is yep
he's not just a ham he's the whole pig
you love to do that line now your father
I've heard tell I've actually heard you
say your father was a very funny guy
yeah very funny guy my arias and you
took him along when you were coming up
in show business you took him along with
you sometimes I did and he would get to
meet some of your heroes is that right
he got to meet the legendary Rodney
Dangerfield oh wow yeah so that was a
total thrill and and when he met him he
was you know Rodney had this habit of
sitting around in his robe and
completely naked underneath and when he
met my father
I said Rodney this is my dad and he
loves you so much we used to watch you
on Ed Sullivan and I laughed before I
even know what did you do what a joke
was and he said hey Percy nice to meet
you my father's name was Percy my whole
life is very literate Perseus Percy nice
to meet you you don't mind if I smoke a
doob do you like that and he started
smoking a joint and then he said to my
dad uh hey sorry I'm sorry about this
man I can't help myself I'm a pothead
you know what I mean I mean this [ __ ]
makes me creative like that and my dad
said that's fine Rodney just do what you
do and and then Rodney said hey you want
to hit this thing and my father quickly
said no no I can't do that if I smoke
that I'll be up to two packs a day in no
time
and Rodney just fell off the chair and
said who is this guy my writers a second
man what is this doctor yeah so you know
that's okay I'm coming are you ready to
reveal yours I might have something
going on here oh wow all right I did the
best I could
you know you've been turned away from me
for quite a bit of time but yeah the
best fake that's pretty awesome I don't
know yes yeah yeah okay all right are we
ready to unveil these yeah here we go
kay you go first and I go okay this is
it's a it's kind of a it's a little bit
younger version of you with the bigger
head talking about bigger hair back he
didn't really capture the fear this fear
and I see self-loathing you're very good
yeah you're worried about something all
right somebody's coming up behind you
over time I didn't I didn't I'm not I
don't do this but I took a shot at it
right here nicely done yeah - kind of uh
mine is a reverse Dorian Gray yes yeah
you'll get older but this is gonna get
younger and younger younger and younger
this picture this is robbing me of my
life s exactly did I have that before
you go I would love you to great a few
spare that right in front of me in
laughs